JAKE ARCHIBALD: Hey, Paul.
PAUL LEWIS: Hello, Jake.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We made it.
We made it across
the narrow sea.
PAUL LEWIS: Big, bleeney wings.
We actually made it.
Help, we landed.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So did you
enjoy the keynote yesterday?
Was it good for you?
PAUL LEWIS: It was, actually.
I was looking at a massive
screen around the whole thing.
And I was like, I've
got to get one for home.
I don't know why.
I can't even justify
that to my family, but--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But
they don't release films
in that aspect ratio.
You gonna have trouble.
You're just gonna basically
see a pair of eyes.
PAUL LEWIS: I know.
I haven't got a plan.
Although what I think is maybe
if you got one of those GoPro
rigs that they showed.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, the ones
on the cardboard segment?
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
That was amazing.
I've got to find a business
justification for getting
one of those in my life.
I don't know.
Maybe I need a stereographic
version of my toilet
at home or something.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: What
would you-- Hang on.
Actually, I know.
So I'm comfortable
going into the toilet
in unfamiliar places.
So what will you guys do?
You're going to have
that set up at home,
so when you're on the
toilet in a strange place,
you can wear cardboard and
have a live link back to home.
PAUL LEWIS: Or just get one
of those screens installed
around the place.
So I can just have
that curves around.
I'm not quite sure
how this works out,
but I think it's very important.
I also noticed in the keynote
that if you stop talking,
people start applauding.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, that
must be really awkward
for presenters, because you
have to just keep making noises.
PAUL LEWIS: Blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Because
otherwise, yeah, an applause
erupts out and spreads
through the audience.
There was nothing
I noticed, as well.
When there was an
applause erupted,
the camera would
switch to the audience
to pick up that reaction.
But the camera on
it always found
a section of the audience
looking completely indifferent.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
Yeah.
It's not quite-- Yeah.
I sort of was like, where's
the applause coming from?
Is it an applause track?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
Yeah.
Well sometimes it was just
an audience who's like, yeah,
whatever.
But then occasionally
you get a section
of people who-- they almost
look like they were trying
to work out who just farted.
You know?
Like there was a sort of like--
PAUL LEWIS: With
that said, there
was some amazing
announcements yesterday.
Like, well what did you notice?
Let me ask you that.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, I would
say, from an engineering
perspective, my favorite
thing was the Google Photos.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Because I went away,
and I was playing around
with-- just doing a search.
Like a search for cats.
But then even more complicated
things, like yellow car.
And it was bringing
up photos I had taken
that were of those things.
PAUL LEWIS: Really?
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
It's kind of creepy.
It's almost like it's
starting to get self aware.
I hope they've got a pair
of pliers next to the cable,
connected to the computer
that's doing all that, because--
PAUL LEWIS: That is
always the mistake
when you've got an
apocalyptic computer takeover.
Nobody remembers that you've
got to be able to cut the power.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yep.
And if that thing
gets into the world,
it can become self
aware, it's going
to be identifying
yellow cars everywhere.
And that's gonna be a problem.
PAUL LEWIS: What happens next?
Nobody knows what
happens next after it
identifies all the yellow cars.
It's probably just
going to sit there,
idly going, no more yellow cars.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yellow
car, red car, cat.
But that will somehow
lead to the apocalypse.
So that's something
to look forward to.
PAUL LEWIS: It kind of has to.
I noticed from custom tabs,
that really caught my attention.
Because I was thinking about it.
It's like today, when you've
got the Twitter native app
on Android, you can
tap into a link there,
and it will load of the WebView.
And then you can
then go to Twitter,
like follow some
links, go to Twitter.
And then it will ask you to
sign into Twitter, in a WebView,
inside the Twitter
[? native ?] app.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Twitter
inside of Twitter inside
of Twitter inside
of Twitter inside--
and browsing the
web in a web view,
it makes me a bit nervous.
Well, it's problematic, because
you don't have the same cookie
jar, the same cache,
the same service where
you've got local storage,
all of those things.
But it worries me when I see
a login screen in a web view,
and in an app.
Because I don't have
access to the URL.
I'm like, well, that looks
like a Google login screen
or a Twitter log in screen.
PAUL LEWIS: But is it?
And you don't want to find out.
You don't want to
be going like, yeah,
I just gave out my password.
But generally, it just felt like
it was a really good match of,
this is Chrome-- it is
Chrome, as you sort of expect.
But from a user, or even
a product point of view,
it's like it's
branded such that it
feels like it's part
of the experience
that you're currently having.
It felt like a really good
understanding of-- you
want the web to be part
of a native experience.
And it just felt like a
really good way of doing that.
So hopefully, I think, we'll
see more people targeting that.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So one
of things that we've
seen be proposed or start
to come out recently
is Facebook instant
articles, right?
And I don't know about
you, but because I'm
such a fan of the web, I was a
little bit. worried about that.
Because it's like
they're saying,
oh, the webs not good enough,
so we've kind of reinvented it.
And if you look at
the JSON for something
like Facebook instant
articles, they'll
have an object that
represents a paragraph.
It will have a type
and the type will
be in [? couplets ?] paragraph.
And it's got a little
bit more metadata.
And then the text
for the paragraph
is actually more
verbose than HTML.
PAUL LEWIS: Really?
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But the reason it
becomes fast is things
like it's able to
preload it, warm it up.
And it does kind of stop.
It doesn't have the features of
the web that make the web slow.
It's not inherently
faster than the web,
but you can't put eight
IFrames within IFrames.
PAUL LEWIS: So
it's like skirting
around those potential
foot [? guns ?]?
Right.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So I'm
kind of really excited
about the custom tabs thing,
from that perspective,
because within the app, you
could warm up the browser,
you can warm up the content.
So you get that instant
feel, but it is kind of
down to developers
to go that extra mile
and well, no-- not
even go the extra mile.
It's to walk back
the extra mile,
and not do the stuff
that slows the web down.
Yeah, reverse, reverse.
Take all this iframes
and scroll handlers out.
PAUL LEWIS: Talkign
about the beeping thing,
I was walking past
the street here,
and was just walking along
on the sidewalk, and all
of a sudden, it's like
wah, wah, wah, wah--
and it was like,
there's a car coming.
Don't die.
I was like--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That's a good
instruction for life though.
PAUL LEWIS: I felt like it
was a very helpful thing.
What was more concerning was
that the volume of the thing
was so sudden and so loud--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You actually
jumped out into the road,
by accident and got mowed
down by an oncoming bus.
PAUL LEWIS: It felt
like it could've
done with a little bit
of easing in there.
It just felt like the user
experience was, don't die,
but you might die from the
thing telling you not to die.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So there's
so many people here.
It's absolutely incredible.
And I don't know about
you, but I'm a nerd.
I'm a proper nerd.
PAUL LEWIS: I had noticed.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So I have all
of the social foibles that
come with that.
And we've been meeting
a lot of people,
saying hi, talking
about the web.
And I just feel like that
amount of new people,
but also people I haven't
seen in a long time.
I'm feeling like I've got a
really high error rate when
it comes to social encounters.
PAUL LEWIS: Absolutely.
I'm exactly the same.
I don't know quite
what to do about it.
Because it's like,
I want to be here.
I want to meet with you,
and I want to talk with you,
but my ego can't really
cope with the fact
that I'm just doing a terrible
job of being a human being.
A sociable human being.
It's like normally
they edit us when
we do videos and all
the rest, to make
us actually seem pretty normal.
So I'm fine with--
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Someone will come up,
and I'll say hello wrong.
Something as simple as that.
In my mind, I'm like, oh,
you messed up a Hello.
It's only going to go
downhill from here.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, your brain
goes into the two track thing,
right?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Commentary
for how terrible a job
you're doing at life.
PAUL LEWIS: The worst one of
those that ever happened to me
was, I was on stage,
and I actually managed
to dislocate my shoulder.
It's something that I've
done enough times now
that it can happen to me.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It almost sounds
like you do it on purpose.
Sometimes.
PAUL LEWIS: Got the t-shirt.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Got nothing
else to do for the next hour.
Might just pop the shoulder our.
PAUL LEWIS: Pretty much.
So I dislocated it, and I'm
in front of all these people.
And my brain went
into that two track.
The one part went, oh you
dislocated your shoulder, mate.
This is not good.
And the other one
was, I always think
as more of a thespian voice.
The show must go on.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Be
the hero of the stage.
PAUL LEWIS: Pretty much.
Pretty much.
And so at that point, I
was just like, back in.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: As
cool as a cucumber.
Pop the shoulder back in.
PAUL LEWIS: And I spoke to
people after, and I was like,
did you realize that I just
dislocated my shoulder?
And they were like, no.
I was like, well, at
least I can cover that.
It's not really a resume
skill, if I'm honest.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Have
you seen-- did you watch
X-Files when you were younger?
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Are you using
[? Victor ?] [? Tombs? ?] Are
you going to stretch down
into a chimney and kill people
at night?
PAUL LEWIS: I
sincerely hope not.
Anyway, back to the web.
One of the other things
that some of the sessions
and so on-- and they got into
things like ServiceWorker.
That's been nice to
come back forever.
We see the one trick pony when
it comes to the ServiceWorker.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Of course.
So it's great to hear that
mentioned loads in session.
But just the
practical uses of it.
So what it was last year, when
we were presenting about it,
was it was just like--
PAUL LEWIS: Coming soon.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
And a couple of
Googlers going, hey, we
kind of made a thing
using a prototype.
We think it's going to be OK.
Fingers crossed.
Hope we don't break the web.
And now we're seeing
people from "The Guardian"
using it for push
messages or just
using it to make
performance better.
PAUL LEWIS: Right.
Because it's the gating
for why the push messaging
and notifications and
all that kind of stuff.
It's like [? SBS ?],
ServiceWorker, blah, blah,
blah.
And we're starting to
build a really strong
re-engagement story
off the back of it.
It's not just like you
get fast bootstrapping,
you get stuff that
works offline.
But you can now start to
kind of say to your users,
would you like me to keep you
updated on any of these things.
So that is very excited really.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, so you
were talking about performance
as well.
If you talk about what
makes a website fast.
Like the whole rail thing.
PAUL LEWIS: We've been talking
about rail, which is response,
animation, idle and load.
And how you can think about
app and site performance,
and bring all that together.
So that's gone down really well.
People are starting to
go, yeah, I understand.
It's put the user in the middle
of your performance model,
so that's been really nice to
share with the attendees here.
Hopefully we'll get more
out about that soon.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Do you think
that's going to happen?
We're going to get a faster web?
Out of this?
Because that's what
we want, right?
PAUL LEWIS: One can only hope.
But in the meantime,
you know, here's
to another year of
the web and I/O.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: To the web.